yeah I think there's no question that
the Iranians have now responded the
Iranian regime has in fact through its
media outlets announced a formally that
it has begun attacks it claims on
several air bases here in Iraq where US
troops are based the aisle on Assad Air
Base which is about 300 kilometres south
of where we are now to the west of the
capital Baghdad has we understand and it
has been confirmed both by saw the Iraqi
sources to us but also the American
media is confirming it through their own
sources in in in the Pentagon it has
been under sustained rocket and missile
attack for some time what is not clear
is the size of these missiles and indeed
as you point out whether or not there
have been any casualties as a
consequence of them but if as the
Iranians are claiming these were
missiles launched from Iran at the air
base then clearly they are very large
that they are substantial enough size to
be able to travel a significant distance
and therefore the possibility of
casualties at that airbase is high
although as I say at this stage we don't
have any details on on those casualties
separate to that up here in in Erbil in
northern Iraq where there is a US
consulate and where there is a large
coalition base housing not only
Americans but soldiers from the U from
the UK and other European nations there
has been there have been reports of an
explosion now we haven't got any details
of that at the moment but the Iranians
are claiming as I say that they have
attacked several air bases and so we may
get clarification on that in the hours
to come but there is no question now
that Iran's response has begun that
there is a big question though over how
Donald Trump will respond to that you'll
remember in the hours after the
assassination of general Soleimani
Donald Trump tweeted a photograph or or
a an image of the Stars and Stripes the
American flag well a very senior Iranian
official at close to the supreme leader
has in
the last few minutes tweeted an image of
the Iranian flag no question the
responses began we await the Americans
response